a growing web of rail
road and sea routes is at the core of
beijing's foreign policy strategy
from china to southeast asia central
asia
the middle east europe and africa the
belt and road initiative is a huge
global project
expanding and integrating infrastructure
networks which president xi jinping has
called
the project of the century
welcome to mombasa traders have been
coming to kenya's oldest city for
centuries the arabs the portuguese the
british and
indians have all tried their hand at
making a fortune here
the latest are the chinese we'll explore
their grandiose ambitions asking whether
dreams in far off beijing
match those on the african continent i'm
rashad salamat
this is belton road china's trade
[Music]
superhighway
mombasa is seen as the gateway to east
africa
at least five landlocked nations
including uganda and rwanda rely on this
port to get goods
in and out the mombasa nairobi standard
gauge railway or sgr
is the nation's biggest infrastructure
project since independence from britain
in 1963. kenya paid 3.8 billion
china arranged the financing and built
what is the start of a rail network that
promises to open up the passage of
people and goods
deep into the heart of the continent
the sgr cuts the journey to kenya's
capital to five
hours down for more than eight for cargo
transported by truck
the belton road initiative is i believe
a good initiative for
for the region the railway link
from ambassador to nairobi i have
reservations about the price that was
paid
for for the rail link however the fact
that we have a rail link now
is creating immense opportunities
leading to reduction in supply lead
times and so on
that's what we wish for there's nobody
else who can compete with the chinese
investment into infrastructure however
when we look at it from an
african perspective or kenyan
perspective investments coming in to
build our infrastructure are very
welcome from wherever they're coming
whether it's american whether it's
chinese or whether it's european
because they need to make us more
competitive the market is there but to
get
connectivity to get our products out
there is a problem
so we hope that through bri that these
markets can be opened up not only to
china
but to all other countries within bri
and that's what we're hoping for
better transport links are vital if
regional expansion is not to hit
the buffers the imf forecasts that the
east africa community will see growth of
6.2 percent in 2019
mombasa port itself is expanding to meet
the challenge
the equivalent of 1.2 million 20-foot
containers passed through this port
every year what's more that figure is
expected to grow by
three to five percent per annum
the business the potential is blindingly
obvious
so far execution has been the source of
a litany of complaints
sure the containers get to the capital
quicker the trouble starts when they get
there
and when the bills arrive the government
says it's listening
and is determined not to create a very
expensive white elephant
sachin goodkas presses roll out billions
of labels each year
people in supermarkets around the world
are unwittingly familiar with some of
them
there are seven cargo trains a day
coming in bringing 150 containers a day
into nairobi from ambassador so that's
almost 800 to 1000 containers a day
which all used to get put onto the
single lane road from mombasa to nairobi
tremendous congestion
fatalities and so on however kenya's
not properly addressed the bottleneck
at the inland container depot in nairobi
and it is heaving with containers so
the congestion within nairobi is hurting
business
do you use it yes we are we are all
even though it's more expensive it's in
fact we were kind of forced to by the
government
so logistics is always two-way right
from ambassador going all the way to
rwanda
and then of course later on it can go
all the way to west africa as we speak
today there is no railway
or roadway going through to west africa
and that can be done
very easy to expand it however when we
talk about competitiveness we're also
talking about
return logistics going back from kigali
all the way to bombasa all the way to
china
and we could have that two-way logistics
becoming competitive this is so key for
all our countries to have export
products and export into those markets
so that
we're competitive both ways bitco is
east africa's leading producer of edible
oils
it also makes detergents and other
consumer products
with factories in kenya uganda tanzania
and madagascar
it sells into 18 regional countries
chairman vimal shah is cautiously
optimistic about the wider impact of
chinese investments
i think there's no doubt about one thing
that china wants to do
much more trade right whether we call it
economic dominance or whatever
they have a competitive edge today
therefore if they start bringing in
their industries here
to produce here to sell to the west what
it does to africa
is not that it's going to be ownership
it's going to be jobs
it creates jobs here in your grow
grab and sustain your number one
position does this worry you
for us as a company bitco we're not
worried because we don't see these goods
that we make here
we don't see these coming from china in
fact china is a good market
for some of the consumer goods with its
population china india both
with their populations they will need
much more food they will need to have
a lot more of products and that's what
africa can do so we've got to look at
the comparative advantage for africa and
say fine
what are the products that we can then
export into china
using the same belt road initiative how
much do you currently then
sell to china or india zero
this glass half full attitude is often
counted by fears that all this
hugely expensive infrastructure is
simply a fast track for china to exploit
new markets
while leaving african countries swimming
in debt
there have also been complaints about
transparency for example how china road
and bridge corporation was given the
contract to operate the line for 10
years
and there was no tender process
beijing's african enterprise is really
based
on trade and not benevolence it's also
inextricably linked to the way the
country sees itself in the future
in a geopolitical sense and beyond
meanwhile for kenya and its neighbors
they see a medium-term locomotive for
growth but down the track
things look a lot more murky some are
raising questions about the level of
indebtedness or
whether or not it's a win-win
relationship coming up we have a look
at whether it can be that or it will be
a situation
where there's only one victor
[Music]
after mombasa containers end up here in
nairobi now that's not
the end of the story it's the start of a
more profound one
opportunities for new markets stretch
beyond kenya's capital
beyond kenya itself to tanzania uganda
rwanda or even europe the question is
did it all come
at a price that they can afford welcome
back to belton road
china's trade super highway i'm richard
salamat
[Music]
our leaders are letting africa go to
china that's my view
i think we need to do it in moderation
while at the same time maintain our
country
we there's quite a lot we can learn and
gain from china quite a lot
but i think we need to do it to some
extent not
get china to come and take over our
country
[Applause]
we do not interfere in the internal
affairs of african countries
impose our will on african countries
attach any political condition
on the economic aid for africa nor do we
seek selfish political gains
and financing cooperation with africa
china is pushing back against criticism
the belt and road initiative loads up
partner countries with debt
it also refutes claims it's aimed at
strengthening beijing's global influence
the chinese president maintains the
initiative as a tool for
common prosperity while the roads rail
and port infrastructure are desperately
needed in africa
the continent's debt pile is rising
about 12 billion dollars in chinese
loans were given in 2015
compared with just over 100 million in
2000
that's according to the china-africa
research initiative
and then there are chinese companies
many of which are state-owned sourcing
infrastructure projects in cooperation
with african governments
some do it with financing from the
export import bank of china
otherwise known as exim bank it's a
state-funded
state-owned policy lender kenya's sgr
between mombasa and nairobi was 90
funded by such a loan i don't think
based on the quantity of cargo the
construction cost the service cost of
the
of the loan and in addition to the cost
of running the train
one way and the other it is not possible
for the sgr
to pay for itself i mean with the people
of kenya payback they obviously will
have to
and the only way we're going to do that
is actually having to suck taxes from
other sectors
and use that to to service this loan a
further one and a half billion dollars
for the next stage of the line is
largely funded by a loan from exim bank
an extension to kisumu will cost 3.8
billion dollars
and kenya is now asking china for half
of that as a grant
instead of a loan what's more to connect
the line all the way to uganda
another 4.9 billion dollars may be
needed
critics of belton road have said that
these countries are mortgaging their
futures that this is going to lead to a
huge amount of indebtedness which would
lead to default which will then
ultimately to china actually controlling
our sways of these economies i don't
think that will happen
everyone's spoken about debt trap
diplomacy
that it's a sinister move by china to
get control of strategic assets
for example djibouti is pretty indebted
and they put up a military base in
djibouti
could they get mombasa port for example
if kenya defaults on its
railway line debts and so on it's a very
unlikely scenario
because the overall trade benefits and
that
we will see emerging from this and
investment and trade benefits we will
see
will supersede these i am aware
that countries often overpay for
the infrastructure however the
infrastructure
in this case was necessary and i think
overall will be a benefit to the economy
and infrastructure builders like china
communications construction companies
see
plenty of opportunities to boost their
own growth
as well as those of african nations it
is the parent of the company that built
and operates the sgr we're going without
i think the whole african continent has
opportunities for development
there's a large young workforce but
economic growth is slow
so there are few good job opportunities
right now i think they're like
china back in the 1970s and given
china's development through the years
i think africa will also embrace
development opportunities
but the steady influx of chinese
companies and workers have fueled
accusations the wealth and opportunities
are not being shared with the local
community
i think that definitely if you look at
the financing for a lot of these
projects as chinese banks if you look at
the contractor as a chinese contractor
so if you're looking for the big ticket
so the person who's receiving
the four or five billion dollar check is
likely to be
some sort of chinese entity and
questions about transparency and
corruption
won't go away i think this is a big
debate going on whether this chinese
debt is serviceable or not
and the issue around whether it's
becoming too heavy and indebtedness and
therefore ultimately
it will end up in chinese hands and they
will own the country
i think what is important here is to
note that there should be no government
guarantees for the infrastructure that's
being put up
this should be done on a private sector
basis where they come in run it operate
it and finance it
and ultimately transfer it at a price so
that they get a good return
as a commercial enterprise look at it
both ways
short term painful long term gain but
the kenyan citizen right now is carrying
a very big burden
in terms of taxes because we want to pay
for the loans that we are taking and
it's interesting that we're still taking
in more uh
with a and see situation because also
unfortunately we have issues of
corruption in the country
which really have diverted some of these
resources from what they were meant to
be
or we are seeing something that was
supposed to be a really big
enterprise or really big project we're
hoping
but it comes out to be a bit substandard
than what we expected
regarding the student group really
obviously there are many things that
actually haven't
uh have not been answered including some
of the contracts that i've been entered
into
the payments of course the payment plan
and everything is is quite clear
but the real costs and whether uh the
costing of individual pieces of
equipment on individual construction
sites and how it all
adds up is something that's still being
questioned and i think it's not as
transparent as
would be preferable for a piece of
infrastructure that is close to
five percent of a gross domestic product
the real question is
are those loans used in the right manner
for the right projects that will
generate the right type of revenues for
the african country
again it comes back to the need for the
african countries
to develop their own perspectives
holistically not project by project on
what infrastructure they need for what
projects
what is the best way to finance these
and then to engage with different
partners whether it's the chinese
whether it's the world bank
on how to go about building these
projects
[Music]
coming up forging africa's future the
past was all about
aid and aid gives us aids it's called
always in death syndrome
i don't take the easy thing by thinking
somebody cheated us
i don't think so i think yes we made a
bad deal but we must take responsibility
for it
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to belton road china's
trade superhighway people come to
markets like this one in nairobi to get
the best deal that they can
it's like anywhere else ultimately no
one is forced to buy
by the same token many people have
accused governments
of not haggling hard enough with beijing
it's clearly not a two-way street
i think uh it's very very profitable for
the chinese farms that are involved in
actually this
they're going to make very handsome
profits from this no doubt um
but i say i mean the ethics of it
notwithstanding but i would say well
they negotiated the best deal they could
get and so as kenyan taxpayers we should
be actually asking tougher questions of
our own administrators and on our own
governors
how could you in broad daylight make a
deal such as this kenyan companies also
want to make handsome profits
but some sectors are frustrated we
export quite a lot of our products
agriculture products to the european
market
but the chinese market is quite is
really untapped
there are some protocols we are supposed
to sign as a government of kenya
so that it can support our growers to
take the products there but it has not
done that
our manufacturing capacity is not not
fulfilled
because we are not fully competitive yet
and we do need government
intervention to urgently address our
competitiveness
secondly the
there are no preferential trade
agreements
also with china at the same time both
manufacturers and kenya's leaders see
the increasing numbers of chinese firms
as a positive
we welcome the chinese manufacturers to
the manufacturing fold
manufacturing is part of the big four
agenda
driven by the government and
we really need as much investment
both local direct investment as well as
foreign direct investment
to onshore into into kenya and create a
very strong manufacturing hub
president uhuru kenyatta's big four
agenda aims at boosting manufacturing to
fifteen percent of gdp
from around about nine percent by 2022
agriculture health and home construction
are the other industries targeted for
growth
just the extent of manufacturing that we
see
is creating thousands of jobs dire lead
required jobs across the continent and
you're seeing it in increasing numbers
the innovation that we are seeing the
chinese bring to africa
sometimes seemingly quite simple but
where they recognize africa to be a key
market
they are innovating for our markets
bitco's chairman says local companies
can grab opportunities if
african leaders pull together bri
is seen by many as being a one-way
street you want it to be a two-way
street so you want access to the chinese
market you think you will get that
so i think this is where we must look at
africa becoming more productive
more producing goods that add value add
more value to our products and really
become emerging
and that's the great hope will it happen
i think it's up to us as africans right
to make it happen to make sure that we
do it in the right manner and become
competitive
today the folly is that intra-african
trade is at
such a low we actually putting up more
and more barriers
within africa against each other and
we're allowing china or america or
europe to come in
you know duty-free and i would take all
the leadership in africa to say
unite because we've talked about oau
you've talked about african union
but it's still talk it's called nato no
action talk only we've got to get out of
that and make
it happen china's africa policy has
shifted now drawing a
clearer line between official foreign
policy and private commerce
beijing created a new development agency
in april 2018
it is expected to play a larger part in
government strategy
as exim bank's role reduces it's one of
the criticism china gets
a lot which is that it is offering these
loans
those loans are originated by the
african countries they are the ones
asking for it
they may have a dream in terms of the
nature of the relationship
but i do not think they are trying to
shape the future of africa
that's not to say aid and lending won't
be influenced by commercial interests
interests which some say still have
access to resources at their heart
chinese companies continue to see an
abundance of opportunity in the
continent's rebounding economy and a
green light to raise their presence
there under the banner of the belt and
road initiative
while china sees huge investment
opportunities what about your average
portfolio manager or your retail
investor
can they also come along for the ride if
you want to invest directly in the
the sort of belt and road initiative
that
you can't do it directly but basically
what you're investing is somewhere where
perhaps it's a hub for african and
international companies
so as the environment gets easier as say
for example the cost of power comes down
then it becomes more easier
or more economic to manufacture goods so
that's the story
so i think for kenya and for east africa
as a whole
you sort of sell the story of access not
necessarily large minerals
or any sort of natural resources that
you get elsewhere in africa
so i think for us it's a sort of a
portal to the rest of africa
that's the way that we would look at it
there's also paying for the thing isn't
it i think in the long term
you have new towns being opened up you
have people who can
do more commerce who can ship goods and
also what it's doing is
moving perhaps the industrial heartland
of kenya away from
parts of nairobi to other parts of the
country so you can manufacture
in naivasha once the planned
industrial hub is set up there and you
can then export
straight out to mombasa and what if
complaints chinese companies are
sweeping up
large government contracts in africa and
white has concerns
about challenges to us influence i think
one thing you've got to tell
very clearly the chinese have a serious
advantage in execution
this is where the europeans were a head
start for the last 50 60 years
in africa did not do much the americans
they ignored africa they did not pay
attention to it and when the chinese
came
in i think they've done serious
execution on the ground they're giving
you better infrastructure
at lower prices and they've upped their
game i think tied aid is gone
now it's execution you can call it
economic dominance you can call it
economic
you know colonization colonization
but africa needs infrastructure now and
it needs to have it done rapidly
that's always been the problem with
foreign aid it's ended up in people's
pockets hasn't it
not always but the past was all about
aid and aid gives us aids it's called
the always in debt syndrome
okay and we don't want to have that what
we want to have now is make us more
competitive
ease our doing business however
we need to make sure that everything has
a clear code of ethics
it's all being done on above board and
there's nothing that's being siphoned
off
[Music]
the stakes are high for both sides for
china the mouth-watering potential of
new markets
they're at large less obviously those
how to tap them
and not be seen as the next colonizer
for the recipients
beijing's initiative offers a
multi-generational change
china may well be a partner but it's
also a competitor
factories like this one can compete with
efficient chinese ones
sadly that's not the norm when thrown
the gauntlet
many have wilted the choice ultimately
is theirs
i'm richard salamat thanks for watching
you